hi i'm jackson and i'm five years old a
welcome tasty junior and today we're
making my favorite birthday cake
it's a vanilla
fruit cake i love to help my mom cook
my favorite food to cook is pizza but i
also love desserts
my favorite thing to do is have my mom
in the kitchen
she lets me come and make tasty junior
videos with her sometimes that i need my
mom
but i like to do elvis and myself
my mom can you help me with this
[Music]
and my mom makes this cake for
everyone's birthday
every year i asked my mom to make this
for my birthday it's nobody's birthday
today
but we just eat this cake both fun
is cooking your favorite thing to do
with me
it's pizza
pizza
i make all kinds of food
sometimes when i whip the cream it
slides somewhere that's why i wear my
apron when i put my hat on i feel like a
little stuff
when i'm cooking at home with my mom we
like to use the tasty ginger cookbook i
make all the recipes at home and it has
my name on it
i have a little brother
brother
[Music]
brother blood not one
bladder i give my little brother a piece
when he wants
well i could save most of it for me
kids are my favorite i can get 200 of
them
this cake is my favorite because it's so
beautiful and it tastes good it's like
having a fruit salad on your cake
because it's so yummy
that's all it was nice meeting you guys
now
going to eat this delicious
cake
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you